over the years jar jar binks has become
emblematic of the Star Wars prequel era
as well as at oten the internet holds up
to argue how terrible those three films
were in the years following the release
of the Phantom Menace fans denounced jar
jar as little more than a cheap money
grab made to sell toys and that was a
best at worst they described him as all
the worst aspects of Star Wars distilled
into one character with some critics
suggesting the character represented a
racist stereotype on account of his
cartoonish accent at the center of all
this though was a man who portrayed
judge' armoured best when he was cast
for the first Star Wars movie almost 20
years ago best was coming off a
celebrated turn in the hit musical stomp
in San Francisco and in 1997 best went
into production on the Phantom Menace
with bright eyes and a cheerful attitude
it's easy to see how much fun he had
behind the scenes of the Phantom Menace
- singing dancing and chipper as ever
even when he was draped in latex during
a searing Tunisian summer bird all that
changed in May 1999 practically
everybody was around back then was aware
of the fun backlash against the
inclusion of Jar Jar Binks in Star Wars
Canon and in fairness bests overwrought
Buster Keaton impression didn't exactly
fit well into a film all about taxes and
trade confrontations even so however
it's easy to forget today just how toxic
that backlash became a number of hate
websites cropped up on the internet
wishing all kinds of horrible things
upon the character even major news
entertainment outlets run stories about
the frothing hate against Jar Jar that
over time gradually became more and more
disturbing some Star Wars fans even led
calls for Gungan genocide comments which
were probably intended to be humorous
but which nonetheless feel particularly
unfunny in this day and age it's not
that Jar Jar Binks was just unliked or
even hated it's that so many people
relish the idea of exterminating
something that only existed as a
fictional construct to his credit George
Lucas too warned best ahead of time that
there might be anger in response to jaha
the same way there had been - the Ewoks
in Return of the Jedi and for what it's
worth Lucas also publicly defended best
when the backlash turned out to be much
much worse than either of them could
have imagined sadly however people can
only hold up against so much public
for so long after taking about as much
as anyone could be expected to take best
became suicidal in July 2018 the actor
revealed in a Twitter post that he
nearly decided to jump off a bridge due
to the media backlash against charger a
backlash that still affects his career
today several months later he opened up
in greater detail how the Erasmus he
faced for playing jar-jar binks pushed
him to consider suicide I just wanted to
play a part over the last 20 years Star
Wars fans have had plenty of time to
reflect on the successes and failures of
the prequel movies and for many of the
people who were around when the Phantom
Menace was released it's given them a
chance to realize that Jar Jar isn't
exactly a treasonous crime against Star
Wars with that reassessment came empathy
and then the online responses the best
confession many apologize for getting
wrapped up in the frenzied fever of Jar
Jar hates fortunately best bad
experience for the Star Wars universe
hasn't put him off making a long overdue
return in 2020 Lucasfilm will debut Star
Wars Jedi Temple challenge a kids game
show featuring a range of physical
challenges and contests all of it will
be hosted by best himself still though
its lucky things turned out so well
sometimes it's easy to forget that the
Star Wars movies are made by people with
real lives and feelings performing their
craft earnestly in good faith best story
is proof that everyone would be far
better off if fans took that to heart if
you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
National Suicide Prevention lifeline at
1-800 to 73 talk
[Music]